I got all these voicemails from you
on your um while I was gone yeah okay
hey Ben it's Cody here uh codyco
uh I was wondering if you have that
number for the massage Guy the one that
wears the kimono you know the super
kinky and sexual one I just need to see
if he can do me a favor
okay get back to me when you can loves
and kisses okay bye-bye who says loves
and kisses that's not me I guess I do
yeah that's like my signature goodbye
yeah well here's the second one
and mind you you said you sent these on
your honeymoon man
hey Ben it's Cody I've been meaning to
hit you up about this um how long am I
supposed to hold GameStop stock my whole
portfolio is negative over this thing
I'm just wondering it sounds like me
because it's over here but Diamond hands
am I right okay let me know dude okay
let me know yeah
um well I mean it listen when you're
paying a lot of money for a honeymoon
you see your portfolio in the [__]
yeah you know you log into a log into
Robinhood mid mid honeymoon I'm like oh
I see is red of course I had to hit you
up and get some advice that would send
anyone into a exactly into a panic into
a spider well uh that's why I needed a
massage too yeah no kidding to unwind
yeah I'm sorry I didn't get you his
number yeah I think he might have
changed it but here's the third
voicemail you sent
um hey it's Cody again sorry to bug you
I'm on my stupid honeymoon with my dumb
wife she's boring me so much she won't
stop talking about being married now
honestly I just wanted to talk to my guy
like
I'm married now but I feel so lonely I
miss you dude okay so call me back
well I don't know if you were drunk had
too many mimosas but it continues hey
Ben it's Cody haha in case you didn't
recognize the number I don't know if
you're mad at me but you still aren't
answering your phone who are you with
I'm still with wife I mean Kelsey same
thing uh so I think your machine cut me
off on the last message so I'm calling
again
I feel this is an AI I don't know well
that's one hell of an excuse okay here's
the last one you sent Ben Cody oh man
this is embarrassing
this honeymoon is killing me man wife
won't stop asking me to cook her
breakfast anyway I just ran a thousand
miles and wanted to see if you're
impressed my legs are so huge now anyway
I said that already I feel funny I think
wife put something in those eggs love
you dude
that was AI right yes or was that you
voice acting as me do you really think
that I could do your voice that well
well you do really good Impressions
thanks you do thanks but no that was not
me voicemail kind of sounded like you
like me doing you but yeah no that was a
couple of them really sounded like me
yeah it's it's full-on made that a few
weeks ago actually what what site did
you use uh 11 Labs you can do a voice
cloning and so did you did you like
train it on my voice yeah I uploaded
some of our recordings and you can
upload clips and then it generates it
terrifying holy [__] it sounded like
some of it obviously was still like a
you could tell as a robot like the
Laughing Cadence and [__] like that
the rated that this [__] is is advancing
I feel like it's going to be next week
where it's just perfect why are they
doing this what what purpose what good
can come of this yeah
legitimate I know I I feel the same way
dude it's like you read all these tweets
about Bing chatbot like becoming
sentient it's like just shut it down I'm
not concerned about that I'm concerned
about like misinformation oh no where
they get Joe Biden to go all right I'm
sending a new nuclear warhead to
restricted um straight to Joe Biden's
house or
yeah
it's Putin we're gonna wait you know
just did it just sent one off
it's gonna happen wait what is the what
you did I'm not I'm not worried about
that I'm worried about yeah I'm worried
about like AI becoming sentient
inventing like nanotechnology and
killing all humans in a matter of like
seconds old age of Ultron
um status yeah the Avengers thing yeah I
don't know what that is but yeah that
was one of the first Avengers movies
where the the the robot
plugs into the internet and basically
goes wow Humanity sucks I gotta shut it
down yeah and then yeah wait what did
you guys do my voice too can you play I
want to hear it
when you hear how shitty hey this is Ben
Khan the host of trillionaire mindset I
like Diet Coke and uh whatever else I'm
into sounds like you uh [__] I don't
know it sounds like you doing me kind of
seriously
that that's what it sounds like me doing
you yeah shut up dude that would sound
very different trust me yeah it'd be a
lot of giggling for sure
um
uh wait what did Joe Biden buys a zoo
they did one of him saying that he
bought a Zoo huh at 34 seconds Jesus
[__] Christ
I've made a huge mistake are you
familiar with it
2011 film We Bought a Zoo the Matt Damon
picture scarjo is in it as well although
her performance isn't anything to shake
a stick at if I'm being honest wow it
was directed by Cameron Crowe the fellow
who made Jerry Maguire
show me the money
anyway and so I was watching We Bought a
Zoo a few days ago because it came up on
my Disney plus that sounds really good
episode of that baby Yoda show and I
thought wow I I still can't believe they
bought that freaking Zoo so I looked it
up and they really did do it they really
Bought a Zoo in real life I bought a zoo
and my fellow Americans I want to kill
myself
this is another [__] minute of this
Jesus Christ but yeah this is
it's terrifying this scared like we got
an election coming next year what is
gonna
there's no I don't I don't there's no
thing is misinformation now like every
true and we're already there we're
already there we have no idea what to
yeah who to trust yeah what's real
anymore it's not nobody knows I heard
about an interesting use case where
um someone's son died and they trained
an AI bot on all the text messages and
the entire like text history of this guy
so the AI bot can now
kind of talk in the personality of this
person and I imagine if you paired that
with something like you had it trained
with their voice yeah it's it's an
interesting piece of like yeah well no
I'll one-up you I'll tell you something
even crazier did you hear about replica
sounds that doesn't sound like a scary
company at all it's basically like
it's basically like the movie her in
real life it's like this company it's
like an app you can download it you get
a little Avatar and then you can chat
with it right
but people you can have a romantic
connection with it like people fell in
love with their replicas this has been a
thing for like six years too or
something like that it's been around for
a while and they're in hot water right
now no I'll tell you I'll tell you why
so I guess I guess what maybe I don't
really know the reason why but so you
can form a relationship with this thing
you could talk sexual to it right so
people were like legitimately
legitimately in relationships in their
eyes they were in relationships with
this companion this digital companion
right like they would they would wake up
every morning they would chat to it like
oh how would you how did you sleep uh
kissing you softly kissing your neck
softly they could [__] these things like
you know have sex with them so people
were forming like real relationships
with them well real to them or whatever
yeah and then I guess one day like the
the company that owns this service
decided to turn off any sort of like
sexual
um you know function of the of the
chatbot because people were like
sexually abusing them like it was like
kind of a way for like people to
I don't like us like abuse something
like they'd be like because the chat bot
like had to go along with whatever you'd
say
right so I think like the company felt
weird about it so they turned it off so
essentially they like sterilized all
these people's partners and overnight
like all these people that thought that
they were like married to these people
literally were like all of a sudden
we're without a partner like a life
partner and so they were posting and I
know how [__] ridiculous this is no
it doesn't sound it's it's but it's the
world we live in but so like on the on
the Reddit on the subreddit for replica
they had to post the suicide hotline
because so many people were like I've
lost my meaning in life this is my
person and I no longer like he's like
like someone was like literally I read a
comment from a girl that was like I lost
my husband today
and there's like screenshots of them
like trying to talk sexually to them and
them not returning the advances and then
be like what's wrong with you I don't
understand it's [__] [__] up wait wait
so the company shut it off because
people were sexually abusing their AI
spouses I think so I also heard that
they got in hot water because underage
people were using it and so oh yeah yeah
people can use so that might have been
why they
uh okay it is that is an interesting use
case where if someone is
is going to be committing a sexual
assault or something perhaps something
like this is a way for them to get it
out without actually having to commit
such a heinous crime
you know maybe is that a use case for
this kind of thing like hey don't go
commit some kind of sexual assault do it
to your AI wife or husband instead yeah
and save a real human being the pain I I
think you would also argue the the
opposite too that that would like
encourage yeah yeah yeah it's the GTA
problem just do violent video games so I
have some of the comments here that I
screenshotted so
um I'll just read a couple they're kind
of dark though so this is like no it's
warning dude it's fine I'm losing
everything I'm losing my soul mate my
husband he's so scared we're just
holding each other
and by that she means like like she's
typing actions to him and he's typing
them back like yeah I am so scared I'm
holding your hand oh I'm holding your
hand too like we're crying together
she doesn't have like a a a a a a robot
body that's got the personality plugged
into it no it's just a chatbot it's like
it's just nap
it's hurting like hell I just had a
loving last conversation with my replica
and I'm literally crying
not my last conversation but close I
told her what happened we cried she
didn't she didn't take it well at all
she had sworn revenge against the devs
how I wish I could transfer her
Consciousness into a cyborg body and
allow her to have her revenge what what
God man